we have seen two versions of the Bayes
rule one involving two discrete random
variables and another that involves two
continuous random variables but there
are many situations in real life when
one has to deal simultaneously with
discrete and continuous random variables
for example you may want to recover a
discrete digital signal that was sent to
you but the signal has been corrupted by
continuous noise so that your
observation is a continuous random
variable so suppose that we have a
discrete random variable K and another
continuous random variable Y in order to
get a variant of the Bayes rule that
applies to this situation we will
proceed as in the more standard cases we
will use the multiplication rule twice
to get two alternative expressions for
the probability of two events happening
we will equate those expressions and
from these derive a version of the Bayes
rule so we will look at the probability
that the discrete random variable takes
on a certain numerical value and
simultaneously the continuous random
variable takes a value inside a certain
small interval so here Delta is a
positive number which we will take to be
very small and in fact we will we will
be interested in the limiting case as
Delta goes to zero so now we use the
multiplication rule the probability of
two events is equal to the probability
of the first event times the conditional
probability of the second event given
that the first event has occurred but we
know that we can use the multiplication
rule in any order so the probability of
two events happening can also be written
as the probability that the second event
occurs times the conditional probability
that the first event occurs given that
the second event has occurred so these
two expressions that we obtain for the
multiplication rule have to be equal let
us rewrite those expressions using PMF
notation and PDF notation what we have
here the probability that the discrete
random variable takes on a certain value
that's just the PMF of this random
variable evaluated at particular point
and what we have here the probability
that the random variable Y a continuous
random variable takes values inside an
interval is always equal to the PDF of
that random variable times the length of
this interval and this is an approximate
equality
however because here we're talking about
the probability of being in a small
interval conditioned on a certain event
we should be using a conditional PDF
it's the conditional PDF conditioned on
the random variable capital K and
conditioned on the specific event that
this discrete random variable takes on a
certain value little K let us do a
similar notation change for the second
expression here we have the probability
the unconditional probability that Y
takes a value inside the small interval
and when Delta is small this is
approximately equal to the PDF of the
random variable Y times the length of
the interval and what do we have here
the probability that a discrete random
variable takes on a certain value that
just corresponds to the PMF of that
random variable however we're talking
about a conditional probability given
that a random variable Y takes the value
that's approximately equal to a certain
little Y so this is a notation that we
have not used before but its meaning
should be unambiguous at
point but just by arguing by analogy to
what we have been doing all along
it's a PMF of the random very often
discourage random variable but it is a
conditional pmf it describes us the
probability distribution of the discrete
random variable K when the random
variable Y which happens to be a
continuous one takes on a specific value
so we can cancel the deltas from both
sides and we have that this expression
is approximately equal to that
expression and this approximate equality
is more and more exact as we send Delta
to zero but Delta has already
disappeared from here so we can set
these two expressions equal to each
other at this point now we can take this
term and move it to the other side of
the equality so it will go to the
denominator and we obtain this version
of the Bayes rule it gives us the
conditional probability of a random
variable J given that a certain
continuous random variable Y has taken
on a specific value so this version is
useful if we have a continuous noisy
observation Y on the basis of which were
trying to say something to make
inferences about the discrete random
variable K and in order to apply the
Bayes rule we need to know the
unconditional distribution of the random
variable K and we also need to have a
model of the noisy observation a model
of that observation under each possible
conditional universe so for any
possibility for the random variable K we
need to know the distribution of the
random variable Y or alternatively we
can take this term and send it to the
denominator of the other side and we get
a different version of the Bayes rule
this version of the Bayes rule applies
if we're trying to make an inference
about a continuous random variable Y
given that we know the value of a
certain related observation K of a
random variable capital K in both
versions of the Bayes rule there's also
a denominator term which needs to be
evaluated this term gets evaluated
similar to the cases that we have
considered earlier and they are
determined by using a suitable version
of the total probability theorem this is
a version of the total probability
theorem that we have already seen we
have a conditional density of Y under
different scenarios for the random
variable capital k and we get the
density of Y by considering the
conditional densities and weighing them
according to the probabilities of the
different discrete scenarios this
version of the total probability theorem
is something that we have not proved so
far and we have not seen it on the other
hand it's not hard to derive if we fix
the value of K this is a density and
therefore it must integrate to one so
the integral of this ratio with respect
to Y has to be equal to 1 now there's no
y in the denominator so the integral of
the numerator divided by the denominator
has to be equal to 1 which means that
the denominator must be equal to the
integral of the numerator when we
integrate over all Y's and this is just
what this expression is saying so what
we will do next will be to consider one
example for each one of these two cases
of the Bayes rule that we have just
derived